et puis on va passer à vue de Russie
avec Elena Volochine bonsoir Elena et on
se retrouve donc ce vendredi pour votre
votre magazine hebdomadaire qui analyse
la propagande de Vladimir Poutine sur
fond de guerre en Ukraine samedi dernier
il y avait une fête nationale en Russie
intitulé Le Jour de l'unité du peuple un
jour férier important pour la cohésion
nationale oui la cohésion nationale
selon une conception du patriotisme bien
précise avec le jour de l'unité du
peuple un jour férier donc c'est une
fête qui était célébrée du temps de
l'Empire russe et réinstitué en tant que
fête nationale par Vladimir Poutine en
2005 elle marque la libération de Moscou
des enveahisseurs polono- Lituaniens en
1612 ce 4 novembre était l'occasion pour
le président russe d'endosser une fois
de plus son habit d'historien et parmi
les figures historiques qu'il convoque
régulièrement il y a le prince Alexandre
Nevski au 13e siècle il a repoussé les
campagnes d'invasion suédoise et
allemande sur la rousse il aurait mis en
place une politique par ailleurs
d'entente avec les envahisseurs tataro
mongol un choix d'entente avec un Orient
potentiellement hostile mais moins
hostile que l'Occident cela nous
rappelle la position d'un Vladimir
Poutine par exemple vis-àvis de la
Turquie ou de la Chine encore
écoutez souvenons-nous de l'époque
d'alexandresk il visitait les princes de
la h de dehor pour résister plus
efficacement aux envahisseurs
occidentaux parce que les tataro-mongols
ne touchaient pas à l'essentiel notre
langue nos traditions notre culture
alors que les envahisseurs occidentaux
eux voulent les
détruire si la culture les traditions et
l'histoire d'un peuple sont détru ce
peuple disparaît progressivement en tant
qu'ethnos ils font comme la neige à la
fin de
l'automne c'est en fait le même dilème
qui se pose à nous aujourd'hui c'est
notre combat pour exister
B un combat existentiel donc sous la
forme d'une guerre contre l'Ukraine oui
que la Russie présente donc
explicitement hein dans son
historiographie moderne comme une guerre
pour sa survie et pour maintenir la
cohésion des Russes autour de cette
guerre il faut agiter en permanence
l'idée que la Russie et son peuple
serait menacé par des ennemis extérieurs
et intérieurs à l'occasion du Jour de
l'unité du peuple les émissions
d'actualité sur les chaînes de
télévision russe ouvrait une fois de
plus sur cette thématique regardez par
exemple les titres de l'émission
hebdomadaire vestini
record d'audience du dimanche soir sur
la chaîne étatique russe Russie à
1 pourquoi veulent-ils cinder la Russie
qui est le principal
instigateur il faut savoir et comprendre
où se situe la racine du mal où loge
donc cette araignier qui veut à tout
prix obtenir notre défaite stratégique
sur le champ de
bataille la Finlande construit un mur
élevé pour se barricader de la Russie le
grillage de 3 m de hautura un fil Barbel
ABR et des B mais où sont les racines de
cette russophobie la Finlande était un
allié sûr et fidèle de l'Allemagne nazie
quel était l'objet de l'accord entre
Mannerheim et Hitler et dans cette
guerre que la Russie présente comme
sacré pour sa survie la religion occupe
une place centrale oui mais on va le
voir juste après parce que je voudrais
d'abord décrypter ces titres là le
premier que vous avez entendu était
consacré aux émeutes antijuive de la
semaine précédente dans la région russe
du Dagestan Vladimir Poutine il parlait
à cette occasion comme vous l'avez
entendu d'araignée référence aux
États-Unis dépint comme les instigateurs
de ces programmes en Russie le deuxième
titre vous l'avez entendu était consacré
au mur que construit actuellement la
Finlande avec la Russie un symbole donc
selon la propagande russe de russophobie
finlandaise sauf que pour la vision
passée comme pour la vision présente de
la Finlande le discours est biaisé pour
ce qui est du mur tout comme pour
l'adhésion d'ailleurs récente de la
Finlande à l'OTAN ce sont des mesures de
protection après l'attaque russe contre
l'Ukraine quant à la référence à la
Seconde Guerre mondiale et à l'alliance
de la Finlande avec l'Allemagne Naas
aucune mention n'est faite du fait que
cette alliance et bien elle s'est faite
à cause de l'attaque de la Finlande par
l'Union soviétique en 1939 à l'époque
d'ailleurs Staline affirmait tout comme
Poutine pour l'Ukraine que c'était la
Finlande et les Occidentaux qui avaient
attaqué l'URSS et non pas l'URSS qui
aurait attaqué la Finlande un mythe de
l'agression préventive donc au fondement
toujours de la propagande russe
aujourd'hui etou voilà pour l'exlication
et donc dans cette guerre hein je le
disais la Russie donc pour sa survie la
religion en tout cas occupe une place
oui on revient donc à la religion plutôt
le clergé orthodoxe il faut dire qui est
devenu avec d'autres piliers un pilier
donc du régime à sa tête le patriarche
Kiril prêche les mythes fondateurs de
cette guerre d'Ukraine le régime met
aussi en scène en trois dimensions cette
histoire instrumentalisée lors d'une
liturgie à Moscou pour ce jour de
l'unité du peuple Kiril le patriarche a
brandi une icône bien particulière
regardez un événement historique à
Moscou lors d'une L à la cathédrale de
l'Assomption au kremelin le patriarche
Kiril a annoncé avoir retrouvé une icône
miraculeuse de 1580 devant laquelle
priait minine et Pojarski la relique
nationale était jusqu'àors considérée
comme
disparu vous voyez devant vous
l'original de l'image miraculeuse de la
Vierge Marie de Kazan espérons que cette
relique garde aussi notre peuple par ces
temps troublé et qu'elle protège notre
patrie des ennemis extérieurs et
intérieurs
alors vous l'avez entendu la mention des
ennemis extérieurs et intérieurs de la
Russie sans cesse ressassée par les
dignitaires du régime l'icône en
question elle serait celle des
commandants kzma minine et Dmitri
porjersski qui ont donc mené cette
insurrection pour libérer Moscou en 1612
vrai ou pas on l'ignore puisque Kiril ne
donne aucun détail sur la façon dont
l'Église orthodoxe aurait
miraculeusement recouvré cette icône
perdue mais ce qui est intéressant c'est
de noter que ce mythe d'une guerre
sainte pour la survie de la Russie
devenu une quasi religion en soit en
Russie et bien il a aussi ses reliques
l'histoire russe moderne d'ailleurs se
réfère aux époques tsaristes on l'a vu
impérial et bien sûr communiste oui
parce que l'idée générale c'est celle
d'une grande Russie qui doit en
permanence défendre ses frontières des
ennemis et ses frontières elles sont
celles de l'Empire il faut se souvenir
que Staline aussi se posait en
rassembleur des terres russes c'est
ainsi par exemple qu'il a lancé ses
campagnes d'invasion de l'est de la
Pologne et des pays baltes en 39 et 40
en 34 Staline est son chef du Conseil
des commissaires du peuple Viacheslav
Molotov ils ont ordonné la création à
Moscou d'un gigantesque parc des
expositions destinées initialement à
présenter le potentiel agricole des pays
d'exunion soviétique autrement de tous
les peuples qui composaient cet immense
pays samedi dernier ce parc des
expositions intitulé vdnra il a
factuellement retrouvé ses fonctions
initiales avec une exposition de 300000
M car consacré au potentiel des régions
russes y compris celui des nouvelles
régions comme l'appelle la Russie
aujourd'hui celle d'Ukraine qu'elle a
envahi et annexé l'exposition se tiendra
jusqu'au 12 avril 2024 les chaînes de
télévision russes y consacre bien sûr
leur reportage regardez des
extraits faire entrer le plus grand pays
du monde des mers du Sud au confin de
l'Arctique sous un même toit était une
mission quasiment impossible mais elle a
été réussie avec Briot les 89 régions de
Russie ont amené le meilleur de ce
qu'elles ont à la grandiose exposition
intitulée Russie sur près de 300000 M
Carr nous avons des choses à montrer et
nous pouvons être
fers la Russie a appris à faire son vin
et chaque année elle réussit de mieux en
mieux 20 vignobles sont représentés et
une dégustation est
organisée vous allez sentir de Bell
notes au goût caramel
fruité le jour de l'ouverture
l'exposition Russie a battu tous les
records il y a eu0000 spectateurs du
jamais vu
à je suis submerg de fierté pour mon
pays il y a tant de choses intéressantes
j'ai envie de visiter chaque région
franchement aucune chance pour que notre
famille aille à l'étranger ces deux
prochaines
années fierté exacerbée pour le pays
mais une fierté isolationniste vis-à-vis
de l'extérieur oui on entend cette
visiteuse dire que plus jamais elle ne
veut en tout cas pour le moment elle ne
veut plus voyager à l'étranger alors
cette exposition elle était avant tout
destinée à attirer les jeunes on l'a vu
les stands sont on le voit à l'image
ultra mododerne tout est monté à grand
renfort de technologie les écoliers de
tous les âges collégiens lycéens ils
sont amenés par leurs établissements
scolaires mais derrière cette vitrine
attriante il y a bel et bien un messages
très isolationnistes et conservateur
témoins les conférences qui sont données
par les digitaires du régime en marge
des stands d'exposition écoutez par
exemple un extrait de celle de Valérie
zorkin le chef du Conseil
constitutionnel
russe nous voyons tous désormais que le
but est de détruire la Russie à peu près
comme cela a été le cas pour l'Union
soviétique et notre nouelle réalité
exige la mobilisation et des efforts
communs de l'État et de la
société voilà le discours d'une
nécessaire communion entre le peuple et
l'État contre les ennemis extérieurs et
intérieurs dans la Russie de Poutine
tout comme dans l'URSS des années 30 ce
sont les mêmes discours ce sont
précisément ces éléments de langage qui
qui servaient à justifier les
répressions staliniennes et d'ailleurs
le chef du Conseil constitutionnel russe
a précisément appelé à durcir davantage
encore les lois russes pour les faire
correspondre aux réformes
constitutionnelle de 2020 qui à leur
tour ont été au fondement des lois
répressives adoptées au moment de
l'entrée en guerre ouverte de la Russie
contre l'Ukraine autre intervention lors
de ce salon de cette exposition de ce
forum c'est celle de niikola patrouchev
le chef du Conseil de sécurité russe
ex-chef du FSB les services secrets
russes
écoutez notre pays repousse toutes les
menaces extérieurs et intérieurs
seulement grâce à sa cohésion a dit le
chef du Conseil de sécurité de Russie il
y a beaucoup de jeunes dans la sont dans
anné
90 céta des temps
troublés imaginez-vous alors que j'étais
directeur du FSB j'étais obligé
d'ordonner que les employés de
l'Académie ne portent pas leurs uniform
dans le
[Musique]
métro mais le peuple plurinational de
Russie uni pour défendre sa
patrie le peuple s'est uni pour défendre
sa patrie contre les ennemis intérieurs
donc ceux qui s'en prenaient aux agents
des services secrets russes ce discours
il vise en fait à légitimer comme étant
représentant des intérêts du peuple le
clan dit des siloviki lagogentoura des
services secrets russes hérités de
l'ancien régime qui s'est emparé du
pouvoir à la fin des années 90 en la
personne de Vladimir Poutine directeur à
l'époque on le rappelle du FSB cette
lutte de clan à travers la décennie des
années 90 est présenté par le régime
poutinien comme une décennie de chaos où
la Russie aurait failli disparaître mais
les réformateurs ont perdu cette
bataille et dans l'historiographie
poutinienne son accession au pouvoir
elle est désormais synonyme de la survie
d'une nation qui risquait de sombrer
dans le libéralisme je soulligne au
passage que la référence de patrouchuf
au peuple plurinational n'est pas non
plus le frit du hasard c'est un élément
de langage qui vise lui aussi à
présenter Poutine comme le rassembleur
des peuples de la Grande Russie en
premier lieu cet élément il est inclusif
du peuple ukrainien que Poutine entend
réintégrer dans cette Russie
plurinationale où les peuples devrai en
théorie exister en bonne entente sous la
main de faire de Moscou merci Elena
c'est tout pour vue de Russie on vous
retrouve la semaine prochaine merci à
vous tous de nous avoir suivi